- [Host] Warsaw, Poland, is
home to some delicious dishes:
like schabowy-mmm pretty good;
pierogi-mmm, yeah;
and, ooh, one sec, yes, and this-
pig's feet in jelly.
Look at the way it's
wobbling, it just wobbles.
This is nóżki w galarecie.
Translated to English, it
means pig's feet in jelly.
Yes, that's a pig's foot in jelly.
This traditional Polish
dish has been served
for over a hundred years.
Barbara has been whipping up the dish
for family occasions for decades.
That's because she thinks pig
feet in jelly is, well ...
- [Host] Thanks, Barbara!
It's claimed that the
first meat jelly dishes
were served in 1518 at a wedding feast
of an old Polish king and queen.
Back then, pork wasn't so popular,
so it was served with
either young chickens
or even fish.
Here in central Warsaw, it's on the menu.
Marek is the head chef; he
knows the recipe by heart.
- [Host] Ooh, vodka!
OK, but what's the deal with the jelly?
- [Host] So it's the
proteins from the bones?
- [Host] Ehh, and now
the most important part:
the taste.
(classical music)
Mmm, mm, mm, mm, mmm pretty good.
(classical instrumental music)